[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
In diesem Video zeige ich dir,
wie du diesen Schnatz machen kannst.
Der ist essbar,
komplett und auch wirklich superlecker.
Den könnt ihr für Motivtorten benutzen als Dekoration.
Und er ist gar nicht so schwer in der Herstellung.
Ich zeige euch jetzt Schritt für Schritt, wie es funktioniert.
Der ist echt nicht so schwer.
[Musik]
Zuerst hatte ich mir überlegt,
diese runden Pralinen zu nehmen,
diese Lindor, aber die sind zu klein.
Also nehme ich jetzt hier die Kuchenreste
und bin eigentlich ganz froh,
dass wir sie nicht schon aufgegessen haben.
Ihr könnt zum Beispiel auch einfach
nur den Schnatz machen als Cake-Pops.
Ja, ich mache jetzt nicht so viele.
So.
Schön zerbröseln.
Und dann nehme ich Ganache.
Und da nehme ich jetzt einfach nur so viel,
dass eine klebrige Masse entsteht.
Hach!
Ich sage es schon wieder.
Ihr könnt auch eine größere Schüssel nehmen.
Bevor sie gekleckert hat,
hat sie doch eine größere Schüssel genommen.
Und jetzt hier schön mit der Ganache verbinden.
Jetzt nehme ich den großen Eisportionierer
und fülle den einmal flach damit
und forme das jetzt hier schön zu einer Kugel,
so rund wie nur möglich.
Guckt mal. Wenn ihr sie in irgendwas reinlegt,
was unten eben auch schön rund ist,
dann werden sie nicht flach unten.
[Musik]
Die Kugeln sind schön hart.
Und jetzt nehme ich hier Blütenpaste und Fondant.
Das Ganze habe ich schon gemischt eins zu eins.
Nicht zu dünn.
Denn ich will jetzt die Kugel damit einkleiden.
Und der Part wird jetzt hier drübergezogen.
Ist am Anfang etwas schwierig wegen den Falten.
Also wirklich so versuchen,
es so faltenfrei wie möglich hinzukriegen.
Aber natürlich muss ich an der Unterseite
die Falten zusammenraffen.
Und dann zwirble ich sie einfach weg
und versuche, es jetzt hier so glatt zu drücken.
[Musik]
Die Kugel lege ich jetzt kurz zur Seite
und mache jetzt schon mal die Flügel.
Und wenn ihr Fondant und Blütenpaste mischt,
dann könnt ihr es auch wirklich viel, viel dünner ausrollen.
Das kommt durch die Blütenpaste.
Jetzt gucke ich mir kurz die Flügel an.
Also oben so rund
und dann hinten so ein bisschen geschwungener.
Jetzt muss ich tatsächlich
>> MURAT: Das kann man aber nicht essen.
>> JOSH: Ja, klar!
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> JOSH: Aber Glucose, Fructose, Zucker...
>> SALLY: Ja, der Josh hat nicht unrecht.
Denn ich arbeite normalerweise immer
mit essbaren Dingen in der Küche.
Immer.
Das ist jetzt das einzige Mal, wo ich wirklich zaubern muss.
Denn ich brauche jetzt Draht,
damit ich diese Rundung hinbekomme.
Zahnstocher würden nämlich alles kaputt machen.
Erst mal halbieren.
Und
dann mache ich hier so eine Rundung
So. Dann mache ich das hier so
und so,
also wie so ein geschwungenes Dreieck.
Und dann nehme ich jetzt Kleber,
wieder den essbaren.
Das kommt hier oben an den Rand.
[Musik]
Dann kommt hier der Draht rein
und wird so eingewickelt.
So haben die das bestimmt bei Harry Potter auch gemacht.
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Gell?
>> SALLY: Also guckt auf jeden Fall, dass euer Draht
ein bisschen länger ist.
Und hier schön flach drücken.
Mh.
Guckt!
>> VOLKAN: Ist der gut genug?
>> SALLY: Von der Größe her, ist das zu groß?
>> JOSH: Nee, voll gut.
>> SALLY: Geht eigentlich, nicht?
Weil der ist ja auch klein und die Flügel sind riesig.
Und jetzt würde ich aber noch
– der hat ja auch so wie so Federn dran –
das hier so ein bisschen einschneiden,
so eindrücken.
Nicht bis ganz hoch,
dass es nicht so ganz zerbrechlich wird,
aber schon filigran.
Ich könnte so voll die Filmrequisite machen.
Ich mache gerade Filmrequisite,
>> MURAT: Ach so.
>> SALLY: den goldenen Schnatz.
[Musik]
Und dann kann ich nämlich
mit dem Pinsel den Kleber hier aufzeichnen.
[Musik]
Ich kann hier jetzt eh so schlecht sitzen.
Aber ich muss jetzt ein bisschen runter
und mache einfach jetzt noch so ein paar Querstreifen.
Also ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, da
bin ich jetzt nicht so genau.
Da gucke ich jetzt einfach, dass das gut aussieht,
dass man erkennt, was es ist.
Aber ich mache jetzt nicht jeden Streifen so genau,
wie sich es gehört.
[Musik]
Gibst du mir den Schnatz? Snitch?
Der fliegt weg!
Ah, der kann noch gar nicht fliegen. Der hat keine Flügel.
Der Schnatz.
Komm jetzt machen wir den golden.
Das machen wir jetzt so.
[Quietschen]
Das war der.
Also jetzt sprühe ich erst mal
beim Schnatz die Unterseite ein,
lasse es trocknen
und dann die Oberseite
und natürlich auch die Flügel.
Und bei den Flügeln auch erst mal die Rückseite.
So.
Und nach der Trockenzeit dann die Vorderseite.
Und solang räume ich jetzt auf
– also wir.
Gell?
[Musik]
Jetzt wird im Prinzip nur noch alles zusammengesetzt.
Also hier habe ich die Flügel vom Schnatz.
Hier muss ich den Draht etwas kürzen
und zwar,
ja, schon so bis da.
Ich habe Angst, dass er bricht.
>> SARAH: Soll ich eine Zange holen?
>> SALLY: Ja. Vielleicht eine Zange ist auch besser.
Kennst du das so, wenn du was machst
und dann weißt du eigentlich, dass es kaputt geht,
und dann machst du es trotzdem?
Und zack. Okay.
>> JOSH: Ich glaube, manchmal will man
einfach eine Panne sehen.
>> SALLY: Der goldene Schnatz, du musst jetzt funktionieren.
Da werde ich jetzt auch einfach Isomalt nehmen hierein
und stecke dann
das Ganze ziemlich gerade rein
so wie bei dem Schnatz da hinten.
Wenn ihr es so macht,
dann kann es nämlich wirklich runterkrachen.
[Musik]
Und jetzt mache ich hier nur noch so zwei Kugeln drauf.
Das hat nämlich der Schnatz da auch.
Und dann ist es fertig.
Dann kann es angerichtet werden.
Puh!
[Musik]